an organization with as many Secrets as
the SCP Foundation requires the ability
to dispose of material that could prove
harmful to the facade of normalcy that
the o5 council desperately wishes to
uphold and because most of the
high-ranking researchers are a bit too
smart and practical to Simply flush
classified documents and unwanted
objects down the toilet that means the
foundation has to get rid of evidence
thorough enough to guarantee that
absolutely no trace of what needs to be
disposed of survives for this purpose
several waste disposal plants are used
as front companies for the foundation
and function internally as a foolproof
way to liquidate hazardous material and
comprising information but not all
secrets are so easily forgotten with the
push of a button and a rare few can
prove too resilient to be burned away
this is the regrettable case of the
anomalies contained within the site now
designated scp-24 19 a place where the
unfortunate consequence of amnestic
experiments has led to the creation of
hateful Immortal humanoids faded to be
sealed within the incinerators of the
facility these Undead freaks are known
as
scp-2419-a and though they were made
from human bodies the Consciousness that
dwells within each instance is nothing
short of Pure Evil every happy memory
and Associated positive emotion was
extracted from the brains of
scp-2419-8 corpses prior to their
attempted disposal in the incinerators
this was done in order to increase the
effectiveness of standard issue
foundation and nestics but the cost of
this minor breakthrough was that these
bodies all of which were once d-class
Personnel had effectively been stripped
of all human qualities given the sorts
of violent criminal backgrounds that
earns an individual the designation of
d-class personnel these former humans
were the last people that should have
been deprived of the love and joy in
their hearts and when the first of these
Psychopathic laughing men crawled out of
one of
scp-2419's incinerators the foundation
learned all too well what an uninhibited
Criminal Mind looked like driven only by
rage and fury that inspired their most
gruesome acts of exploitation and
violence in life their pain has made
them too hateful to succumb to the
Flames they are the archetypal Sinners
of a burning hell that the foundation's
best intentions paved the road to and
when they break loose all that Hell
Breaks Loose with them but no place of
the dam leaves its Gates unguarded
Dante's Inferno posits that the ancient
Greek mythological figure Minos
Serpentine father of the Minotaur and
judge of wicked Souls guards the pit of
Hell with Stern vigilance the Greeks
themselves favored the image of Cerberus
a 3 headed hound that served its Lord
Hades as a watchdog for the ancient
Egyptians there was Emma the Devourer of
the Dead who consumed the hearts of the
unrighteous in the afterlife while this
sort of guardian beast is not officially
on the foundation's payroll the concept
turned out to be alive and well in the
present day when
scp-682 the hard to destroy reptile
stood against the Laughing men and gave
them the fight of their tortured
unliving existence it all began when the
guard stationed at scp-2419 began to
hear banging from inside one of the
incinerators it seemed as though the
scp-2419-a instance on the other side
was determined to breach containment so
mobile task force beta 7 the mass
Hatters were called in to stand with all
weapons at the ready but this was
exactly what the instance wanted as soon
as the Armed Force had fully assembled
The Laughing Man inside ripped the door
from its hinges it proceeded to use it
as a cover and run full speed towards
the mobile task force who opened fire
immediately
scp-2419-a were known to possess
extremely fast regenerative abilities so
it would take a lot of punishment to
slow this instance down but this was no
unthinking zombie and the instance broke
its charge the second it was in the
midst of the mobile task force agents to
twirl the door around like a trained
martial artist this not only sent the
incoming bullets ricocheting everywhere
causing many of the beta 7 operatives to
be hit by their own friendly fire it
also allowed the instance to bludgeon
several agents with sides of the door as
the remaining mobile task force members
retreated to a less exposed vantage
point where they could employ Heavy
Artillery the instance used this moment
of confusion to pitch the Door backwards
towards the incinerators in a boomerang
trajectory the force and spin of the
door knocked two more incinerator doors
off their hinges and caused two other
instances of scp-2490
to emerge one who was so thoroughly
decomposed that it appeared to be more
than a flaming skeleton sprinted forth
and threw handfuls of hot Cinders at the
foundation agents it used its still
burning body to ignite a few of the
closest agents laughing with sadistic
Glee as it did so seconds after the
emergence of the two new instances a
grenade launcher was fired at the first
Escape e the blast was enough to deal
significant damage but the instance was
indifferent to its own pain it pointed
to the agent wielding the grenade
launcher and a moment later the third
instance was at the agent's throat
strangling him to death who was starting
to become clear to the mobile task force
that this was no random Containment
Breach it was a coordinated escape
attempt by three ruthless criminal
masterminds when their time contained at
the site
scp-2419 had probably decided there was
some truth to the old adage that misery
loves company and indeed these 3D class
were some of the best of the best when
it came to being the worst of the worst
d1576 formerly police Lieutenant
Campbell farage a riot cop with a
serious taste for Carnage whenever the
streets of the city Precinct he presided
overturned violent farage always made
sure that the violence didn't die down
too quickly his nasty pension for
bludgeoning suspects and citizens alike
with his riot shield did wonders for the
Escape Plan he had coordinated with his
fellow laughing men he was eventually
tried and sent to a supermax after
picking a fight with several other
officers in the line of duty a fight
that resulted in a pair of rookie
officers who opposed his violent methods
being hospitalized with permanent Comas
the skeleton was d-4483 Damien Lambert a
prolific arsonist who terrorized Three
Counties while avoiding detection under
the guise of being a sovereign citizen
if there was ever a person who wanted
just to watch the world burn it was
Damian lamb he was caught in the process
of setting fire to an elementary school
and was thankfully apprehended before
any of the kerosene he had poured
through the Halls ignited when the truth
about his previous history of Pyromania
came out Lambert faced death row until
the foundation chose to recruit him as
d-class then there was
d2316 Arnold Roper who was better known
as the Illinois Strangler responsible
for over 50 deaths in two decades before
he was arrested and detained while he
mostly used his bare hands to do the
deed Roper was fond of using metal
chains and heavy-duty choke collars
usually worn by animals to perform his
namesake act of violence Roper wasn't
just brutally strong he was crafty too
and the trio of Laughing Man had him to
thank for some of the finer points of
the Escape Plan the three now Immortal
d-class also had one thing in common
each of them had met the ends of their
cruel and violent lives at the jaws and
claws of
scp-682 and now that they had
outmaneuvered and slaughtered mobile
task force beta 7. their only Collective
goal was to get revenge on the monster
that condemned them all to the fiery
hell of the incinerator The Laughing Man
soon breached the limits of the scp-2419
containment site and began making their
way Overland towards the facility where
all of them had met their original fate
they knew they needed Wheels to get
there so the instances made their way to
the nearest gas station from the waste
disposal plant they'd come from and made
short work of the staff Lambert stocked
up on lighters kerosene and Duraflame
while farage took the emergency shotgun
that the cashier hadn't had time to fire
in her defense it would have been
difficult to accomplish much of anything
with Roper's hands clasped around her
throat once the trio of Undead
Psychopaths had stocked up on weapons
they waited for a suitable vehicle to
pull into the lot and before long there
was
a family SUV with a happy family inside
no less farage ordered Lambert to keep
his fire starting tendencies in check as
a gas station explosion was the last
thing they needed right now the former
Rye Cop made his way out to the car and
used the shotgun to threaten the family
out of the car family road trips can be
stressful but rarely does one expect to
be carjacked by a gang of the undead
faraj told the Unlucky Mortals that he
wouldn't hurt them if they let himself
and his two friends use their car and
true to his word he didn't fire a single
shot the family were all added to
Roper's list of victims instead after
that the three men took to the wheel and
with only their hazy memories of pain
and suffering to guide them drove
relentlessly towards the foundation
facility with their enemy scp-682 was
contained the three had made sure to
leave no human alive at their original
containment site and would allow no
Witnesses who saw their anomalous
corpse-like forms to survive they
couldn't afford to give the foundation a
heads up that the Reckoning was on its
way in a family motor vehicle meanwhile
at the Laughing man's intended
destination
scp-682 was having another perfectly
routine day of painfully soaking in a
tank of corrosive acid this was par for
the course for the reptile and it found
itself as eager as anyone else stuck in
a rut to get a break from the repetitive
mundanity of containment little did the
human-hating monster know it would soon
get its wish a few hours later the
facility was shocked to find that
several fires had been lit at the
fringes of the testing units these were
no freak accidents but rather the work
of Damian Lambert the arsonist still had
memories of all the times he wished he
could just burn his jailer's buildings
to the ground and had targeted the most
vulnerable areas for combustion the
Flames threatened the Integrity of
several areas of the facility and
multiple containment breaches were
imminent if the blaze couldn't be kept
under control while any available agents
with firefighting experience sought to
minimize the damage the researchers
evacuated to safer parts of the building
bringing any sensitive documents and
flammable items far away from the
affected sections this kind of
pandemonium was exactly where officer
farage thrived and he soon entered The
Fray causing enough commotion that Roper
was able to slip deeper into the
facility completely undetected this
turned out to be the perfect role for
the Strangler as he hadn't eluded the
police for 20 years of his life just by
being lucky faraj and Lambert would both
join up with him after they were
finished having their fun for now his
task was to locate the containment unit
of scp-682 and give the Beast a taste of
what the trio had in store along the way
he made sure to obtain some durable
metal chains from a different
containment unit he likely released some
kind of Elder evil in the process but
Robert didn't care about the
consequences the bottom line was that he
was always able to do his best work when
he was armed it wasn't long before he
found the large chamber which housed his
most hated foe
scp-682 Roper laughed maniacally as he
approached the creature floating in its
acid tank remember me Elizabeth the
Strangler said sporting a wide grin The
Monster simply growled back at Roper
wishing to tear him apart Roper chuckled
again and wrapped the iron chains around
the vat with all the considerable
strength of his Immortal muscles the
Strangler pulled the chains taunt and
shattered 682's containment unit the
anomalous chain snared the creature's
body holding it in place how about now
Robert taunted 682 he laughed but the
creature left back
said the reptile I don't remember
you are disgusting
the monster lunged towards a nearby wall
and burst through dragging Roper along
with it by his chains still wrapped
around the creature's body 682 Twisted
in turn flinging Roper against every
wall and obstacle in sight but to its
surprise The Stranger was regenerating
and his grip on the chains was
unyielding back down the hall farash was
still continuing his Rampage when he ran
into an unlikely adversary Dr Alto cleft
stood between the Laughing Man and the
other researchers and as usual the good
doctor was packing heat he told the
other researchers to go on without him
while he contained the scp-2419 instance
on his own a bold move to be sure but Dr
clef had made the same mistake he was
always making by assuming that guns were
the solution to this problem farage
laughed off the bullets and slammed into
Dr clef with enough Force to leave a
crater in the wall behind him he
followed up with a merciless barrage of
punches beating the armed researchers
since less and only relenting for a
moment to steal a few of his prized
Firearms with a blow that would have
taken the life of any normal man farage
struck Dr clef once more and left him
lying there a hair's length from Death
Dr clef's anti-anomaly field may have
protected him from reality warpers but
it did very little against being kicked
repeatedly very hard in the face
elsewhere Lambert had made his way into
the facility setting more fires as he
went the arsonist skeleton was a
terrifying sight to all that beheld it
and when the guards realized that none
of their weapons would have any effect
most of them started to run away from
Lambert rather than towards him all
three laughing men would soon be upon
682 and then the fight of their
afterlives could truly begin until that
moment Roper was buying his Partners in
hatred more time the chains he had
stolen were no ordinary medal and with
them he had managed to keep 682's Jaws
shut while he pounded away at its
exposed ribs with his inhuman strength
Roper had killed more people than either
of his former d-class compatriots but
all that seemed to mean nothing in the
face of this invincible reptile the
shame and powerlessness he had once felt
as the creature had mauled him to death
made his Immortal heart beat without
rage when he was alive the Illinois
stranger had always thought that his
gift for murder made him better than the
average person A man among men but this
thing had made him feel weak in his last
moments of humanity and that sickening
emotion of weakness was still sliding
around in his soul with all of the other
Despair and Malice if his fate were to
live forever as a dead man walking then
he would make damn sure that any
humiliation he suffered would be paid
back threefold this soup of impotent
Fury bubbled within Roper as scp-682's
strength suddenly increased shattering
the weak link of the chains and sending
the hapless Strangler flying backward
at that precise moment farage leaped out
of a nearby hallway and Unleashed Dr
clef's Arsenal on the reptile this
sustained fire irritated the creature
and it turned its focus towards the
unliving dirty cop it ready to charge
only to be suddenly held fast by Roper
who had grabbed its tail farage fired
until there was no more ammo then pistol
whipped the creature in both of its eye
sockets
scp-682 thrashed and struggled so the
men began to circle the reptile and
Alternate delivering formidable body
blows they took far more damage than
they could dish out with their bare
hands but the Regeneration that their
preter natural hatred granted them meant
that both instances could theoretically
keep this up all day Roper grabbed a
broken length of the anomalous chain
while farage picked up a metal table to
use as a makeshift riot shield the
Beatdown continued as 682's eyes
regenerated along with several new
sensory organs to give it a full 360
degree view of the pitched brawl that
was taken place a fiery explosion blew
open a nearby wall an in-walk Lambert
still skeletal and laughing as
uproariously as ever he threw a Molotov
cocktail at 682's back causing the
creature to ignite immediately the
reptile Lord and sudden Agony farage
Lambert Roper regrouped as the creatures
flank and pushed together until they
forced it back through the hole where
the arsonist had entered from they were
now all together in The Inferno the
three laughing men who refused to die
and the indestructible monster that made
them into what they were Roper quickly
nodded the chains and wrapped them
around one of the creature's claws
securing the other end around his waist
like a trained boxer he bobbed and
weaved pummeling the Beast with all he
had and he stepped back from scp-682 was
met with the immortal man shifting his
entire body weight to pull the
creature's leg out from under it barrage
wedged his shield into the creature's
Open Jaw widening it to an uncomfortable
degree and temporarily limiting 682's
bike Force he took out the shotgun that
he had stolen from the gas station and
blasted it down the reptile skullet when
that plan had run its course he started
clubbing 682 about its neck and head
with the butt of the shotgun Lambert
simply continued to douse the arena with
more flammable material especially
himself and the creature he climbed onto
682's back with his burning bones and
hammered away at its defenses with
literal fists of fire the arsonist was
incapable of articulate speech due to
the damage to his body prior to his
death but if he could speak he would
probably be celebrating the fact that he
had become what he had always wanted to
be Damian Lambert was no mere Pretender
with a fetish for fire he was fire
itself a brightly burning God of
destruction that left no inch of the
world unburned and no molecule of oxygen
unconsumed his mother and father would
be proud of him as they waited in hell
for the Sun one who would never arrive
the son who would make the planet they
left behind into a true hell where he
would reign supreme that is until
scp-682 stole that dream out from under
him with a flash of blue and green from
deep within 682 began to burn with a
never-before-seen chemical reaction an
impossible event that could only be
described as anti-fire the turquoise
anti-flames devoured the orange and
yellow ones leaving Lambert in a state
of panic which was soon shared by his
fellow Laughing Man the three former
d-classes had gotten so used to the
torments of the incinerator that the
idea that anything could be more painful
had never occurred to them and yet here
it was the anti-fire which devoured all
flames and directly inflicted
unimaginable suffering to the trio of
instances every particle if they're
still regenerating bodies felt as if it
were ice cold and melting into
nothingness at the same time numbed and
broken all over again
The Laughing men were consumed all over
by the anti-flames and fell into a state
of suspended animation with the
foundation finally getting everything
back under control 24 hours later
scp-682 was contained in a new acidic
chamber there were some new ordinances
from all present and surviving
researchers about exposing it to fire as
the anti-flames It produced were
considered too hazardous to ever exist
within the facility again as for the
three laughing men who had escaped from
scp-2419 they were returned to their
containment units inside of the
incinerators and never exhibited signs
of aggression or Escape attempts ever
again a psychological profile of farage
Lambert and Roper that all of them could
still feel the sting of the burns left
by 682's anti-fire to this day and that
not even exposure to Natural heat and
fire could ever reduce that pain now go
check out could scp-682 be contained in
the back rooms and evil monster created
by a CP Foundation SC p2419 The Laughing
Man for more of today's terrifying
combatants in action